welcome back to New rockstars I'm Anna
vanston and this is a breakdown for the
trailer of The Last of Us episode nine
AKA
what a journey it's been remember when I
made the video about why you need to
watch this show aren't you glad you
listen to Pop Anna and it might be
obvious but there's gonna be spoilers
for the whole season up until now but
I'm not going to give any future game
spoilers whatsoever until the very end
where I will give you plenty of warning
I got you and if you haven't played the
game maybe consider just leaving a
comment instead of reading the comments
this time if you have played the games
there will be plenty of time for
conversation after the episode airs but
this is the finale so please don't spoil
it for others that includes the Last of
Us Part two before we hop in a quick
reminder to check out nerdyright dot
shop where you can celebrate the finale
of season one with this The Last of Us
inspired shirt lost in the darkness
support the channel and check out all of
our awesome merch options at
nerdriot.shop now let's get into the
trailer after all we've been through
can't be for nothing
we open on Joel and Ellie walking down
the highway coming in on Salt Lake City
this has clearly been quite the trip
from Silver Lake since we've made the
jump from snow to Greenery again this is
overlaid with Ellie saying after all
we've been through and the ticking of a
watch in the background Joel's watch
being an important symbol throughout the
show it reminds us not only that the
season is coming to an end but that Joel
and Ellie's journey is coming to an end
as well this realization with a healthy
dose of what they've endured seems to
hit them too as in the next shots
they're walking silently with a far-off
expression on both of their faces
neither of them looking particularly
excited about what's next is the ticking
in the background slows kind of makes
you wish they just get off at Reno and
hit the casinos instead Ellie then sits
in a car looking pensively at her bite
mark scar with the voiceover it can't be
for nothing but the way she says it
almost as a question mark at the end
showing a little lack of resolution the
ticking forebodingly stops in the next
shot as what looks like a stun grenade
is rolled towards them and explodes
clearly they're not alone The Last of Us
May is clear that the apocalypse is
gross there are tendrils coming out of
people's mouths we can hold ourselves to
a higher standard of hygiene thanks to
quip quit makes keeping your mouth
healthy easy equip's electric toothbrush
has timed Sonic vibrations with 30
second pulses to guide a dentist
recommended two minute clean and their
water flosser can give you a gentle or
deep clean at the touch of a button and
Cribs gum Sterner kit fits in just about
any purse or pocket for on-the-go Dental
Health quip has a special deal running
now for fans of the last of us but it
involves a tough choice you gotta choose
between Joel and Ellie to cast your vote
in the quick apocalypse go to
getquip.com infected once their cast
your vote by either using Joel or Ellie
as your promo code either code will
automatically get you 20 off any quip
water floss or quick toothbrush or gum
starter kit but if your favorite
character ends up getting the most votes
quick will send you a special power up
to help you fight off the plaque monster
which is like a bloater that lives in
your mouth make sure you get your votes
in before midnight on March 8th will
announce the winner on the finale
breakdown that's getquip.com infected
and use promo codes Joel or Ellie to
vote for your favorite character
[Music]
there's no halfway with this we then see
a shot of a woman running through the
woods we already know that Ashley
Johnson the voice and mocap actor for
Ellie in the games is playing Ellie's
mom in the show which is very analogous
and very cute Ellie's mom's name is Anna
which yes is very weird for me and we
see her for a brief moment in the season
trailer holding Ellie as a baby wavy
hair green jacket we think she'll get
more screen time like a scene running
through the woods and the kind of
awkward way she's running makes me think
she's likely still pregnant at that
point we see Joel urgently walking
through a very spooky tarped off hallway
with a red light notably Sun's Ellie and
then Joel pacing down a hospital hallway
with an assault rifle which he Fires at
least one body already in his wake we
know that the whole point of this
journey was to get Ellie to the Firefly
stationed at the hospital in Salt Lake
City and unless we're getting true to
the two hospitals in this episode this
is probably Saint Mary's Hospital that
we're seeing
we finished what we started
next we see a pregnant Anna yes still
weird with cuts on her legs scrambling
against a wall and a terrifying infected
woman with tendrils coming out of her
mouth that's like crawl running towards
her cranning nope the pattern of cars on
the curtains and the bright blue chest
in the background make me think that
this is or used to be a kid's room or
nursery and then finally we get Ellie
and Joel standing on a rooftop with
Ellie telling Joel we finished what we
started with Joel waiting a little too
long before nodding and that is where
the breakdown for the people who haven't
played the game ends come back after
soon why not thank you for watching
bye-bye goodbye all right now that's
just us gamers in the room it was too
far I could feel it a whole lot of these
story beats are very familiar but with
the helping of Ellie's mom on the side
that's
but it seems like we'll be treated to a
few time jumps that show part of her
story whether it's just one long one
maybe a cold open or whether it's
several sequences intertwined with the
action of the episode like maybe a
sequence of Anna interesting Ellie to
Marlene we'll have to see Ellie might
even get the scoop on why Ellie's father
isn't ever mentioned either way it's
cool to get an exclusive peek into this
story that we only got pieces of through
tape recordings and a tiny bit of
dialogue in the games Jewel going
through the hallways with a gun and the
matte shot of Ellie looking at her bite
mark scarring and the car indicates that
he's gonna make the exact same decision
that he made in the games and the
audience who hasn't played the game has
unknowingly gotten a taste of Joel's
decision to save his world over saving
the world and they introduced that
concept through Henry and Sam you think
the whole world revolves around him that
he's worth
everything the parallel of Henry risking
all of the Kansas City Rebels lives in
order to get Sam medicine for his
leukemia very nearly parallels Joel's
situation just on a much smaller scale
and in that episode the majority of
viewers found themselves on Henry's side
empathizing with his decision which when
you boiled it down placed the value of
the individual over the value of the
group but Jill's decision to save
Ellie's life over allowing a vaccine to
be made that potentially might save
millions of lives was a much more
controversial one to players of the game
and it's gonna be really interesting to
see if the tone and Vibe of the show
result in similar discourse among
viewers I'm also intrigued to see how
much dialogue they add because one of
the added benefits of making this show
that Neil druckman didn't have when
making the first game is the foresight
of what happens in the second game and
not spoiling the second game I think
that foresight might add some extra
dialogue to the show's finale that
wasn't in the first games finale but
we'll leave that for now the final shot
of the episode trailer seems to be
straight from the scene where Ellie and
Joel are on the rooftop and Joel says
they don't have to go through with it
and honestly the only thing I can think
of is the proximity of this moment to
the giraffe moment they unfortunately
didn't have any giraffe shots in the
trailer which made me uneasy considering
it's such an incredible scene but the
stuff giraffe in episode 2 in the
giraffe poster in episode 6 made me
think it might be the last of us has
also been rumored to have shot scenes at
a zoo in Alberta which strengthens my
theory but we've also had the scene with
the monkeys so you never know I feel
like they have to include it though
right they got it I mean Marlene also
isn't in the trailer and she plays a
pretty dang big role in the whole
shebang so I'm holding out hope speaking
of Marlene while those people who have
played the game think we know how it's
gonna go you know you never know drunk
men and Mason have tease changes
throughout the series maybe Marlene
walks away on skane I personally am
rooting for a return to the musical
ending it's not for you to decide
regardless I cannot wait for this final
episode and after the finale airs be
sure to catch our Sunday night after
show as well as our breakdowns and other
fun The Last of Us videos that will
follow until then you can follow me on
Twitter at it'sanavanston and follow And
subscribe to new rockstars at new
rockstars for more breakdowns of
everything you love endure and survive
friends
[Music]
thank you